sabemos que es directamente proporcional
a x si es igual a 30 cuando x es igual a
6 determina el valor de x cuando ya es
igual a 45 guau esta es mucha
información vamos poco a poco deja de
empezar con esto con che es directamente
proporcional a x que llega directamente
proporcional a x en símbolos simplemente
quieres decir que ya lo podemos escribir
como k por x donde k es una constante
donde k es un número entonces sería
bueno poder conocer este número vamos a
seguir a ver si podemos tener
información que nos permita obtenerlo
entonces dice si es igual a 30 cuando x
es igual a 6 estos son la información
nueva entonces sabemos que es igual a 30
cuando x es igual a 6 vamos a poner esto
en la igualdad que tenemos aquí entonces
llévale 30
cuando x es igual a 6 pero esta
constante sigue aquí verdad sigue siendo
k por 6 ok entonces esto está muy padre
tenemos que 30 es igual acá por 6
entonces de aquí ya podemos despejar acá
cómo le hacemos para despejar acá pues
vamos a dividir entre 6 ambos lados de
la de la igualdad
aquí entre 6 en 36 de este lado también
entre 6 el chiste es que estos 6 se
cancelan y por lo tanto nos queda que
acá es igual a 30 entre 65 es igual a
acá por lo que es lo mismo acá es igual
a 5 entonces esto está súper bien la
información que nos da esta parte del
problema es que ya no sólo es una
constante por equis sino que sabemos
exactamente quién es esa constante que
ya es igual a 5 veces x muy bien
entonces vamos a la última parte del
problema y se determina el valor de x
cuando ya es igual a 45 cuando oye es
igual a 45 entonces ahora debemos de
poner aquí que vale 45
entonces tendríamos 45
es igual a 5x y justo lo que nos piden
determinar es el valor de x pero ya está
fácil encontrar el valor de x aquí
simplemente dividimos entre 5 a ambos
lados de la igualdad entre 5 entre 5
estos se cancelan y de este modo nos
queda nos queda que 45 entre 5 o sea 9
es igual a x 9 es igual a equis y para
que se vea un poco más bonito déjame
escribirlo como x es igual a 9 muy bien
entonces terminamos con la información
que nos dan pudimos concluir que x es
igual a 9